it's great to welcome to the program
today Fabrizio Benedetti who is joining
us from Italy he is professor of
physiology and neuroscience at the
University of Turin Medical School and
we are going to talk about the placebo
effect so I think a good place to start
professor is I think a lot of people
don't even understand what we mean when
we say the placebo effect so let's start
there what is this phenomena known as
the placebo effect yes indeed Teresa
there is a lot of confusion about these
words placebo on the one hand and the
placebo response or placebo effect on
the other and a usually placebo is
defined that inert substance in our
treatment with nor therapeutic
properties and the placebo response is
the response after placebo
administration so the main confusion is
that usually the focus of attention is
on the placebo itself because a placebo
is the inner treatment but I mean what
we have learned over the past few years
is that when we started a placebo effect
actually we studied the psychosocial
context around the therapy around the
patient so when we talk about placebo
placebo is the inner treatment with no
therapeutic properties and the
psychosocial contests around the patient
so when we want for example when we give
a placebo actually what we do is a
simulation of a therapy it's a fake
therapy in this way we can eliminate the
specific effect of the therapy for
example the specific effect of a drug
and we can study the psychological
component it would be better to say the
psychosocial component because you know
in the sack Sasha contest there are so
many stimuli social steam
sensory stimuli which tell the patients
now there will be an improvement in your
condition in your medical condition so I
would say that the best definition of a
placebo is that a placebo is the
psychosocial context which means the
psychosocial component of any therapy be
it pharmacological or not and this is
very relevant to people's everyday lives
arguably in more ways than the average
person is sort of aware of I mean a
common one is you'll see a commercial
for some pharmaceutical and it will make
a claim like for example 60% of patients
had improved sindh symptoms when taking
this medication and very often in very
small print along the bottom of the TV
screen you will see something that says
as compared to 50% improvement for
patients receiving a placebo and that is
a very different scenario on a drug that
is only marginally more effective than
the placebo then something that is 60
percentage points more effective than no
treatment that's one example right with
pharmaceuticals but in what other areas
of life is placebo relevant well you
took about about a clinical trial
setting ever before for drug companies
of course a placebo is is a very
important topic because when you want to
validate a new treatment and you can use
a new therapy actually you have to
compare the new treatment with a fake
treatment with the placebo the other
areas in everyday life is a routine
medical practice of course a routine
medical practice there are so many
placebos and there is another area or
everyday life which is sport and when we
talk about clinical practice we we can
we can talk about the pain reduction or
reduction on any other symptoms like
motor performance in Parkinson's disease
but when we talk about sport and
physical performance it is not
surprising actually that you can
improve performance physical performance
in the setting of different sports
by using a placebo which means if you
change the psychosocial context around
an athlete for example you can improve
his or her physical performance so there
are many settings I would say that today
we are today we are working on the three
different settings the first setting is
the clinical trial setting which is
quite important for drug companies were
actually not only drug companies of
course but any clinical trials the
second setting is a routine medical
practice and the third setting is a
physical performance and sport there is
sometimes a misunderstanding that if a
placebo works to improve some condition
or to reduce some symptom that the
symptom or the cause of that symptom
must have been psychosomatic to begin
with is that an accurate assessment or
is that mistaken it's only partially
true actually because it's partially
true because it is true that whenever
the psychological component is important
in a medical condition like anxiety like
depression like motor performance in
Parkinson's disease I mean the the
psychological component is very
important in motor performance like pain
you know so anxiety depression pain
motor performance it is true
psychological component is really very
important so placebos work whenever the
psychological component is important but
it is partially true your session
because because we know that there are
many other mechanism in placebo
responsiveness for example we know that
there are some unconscious placebo
responses which works for the immune
system and in the immune system the
psychological component is very small
if any so I mean if if we want to
discuss different mechanism of the
placebo response so we have to separate
for example anxiety or Parkinson's
disease from the immune system
you know the main point I think this is
a very important point is that as far as
we know today there is not a single
placebo response actually there are many
placebo responses across different
medical conditions and across different
therapeutic interventions so if you ask
me usually people ask me it would tease
the mechanism of the placebo response
this is the wrong question the correct
question is what are the mechanism the
plural across different medical
conditions so to answer your question
your statement is partially true some
mechanism involve expectations which
means the psychological component some
other mechanism don't involve the
psychological component at all because
everything is unconscious it is outside
our our you know awareness our
consciousness how does that apply to
there's a study I read about and I'm
sure you're familiar with it where there
were a number of patients who were
identified as needing a surgery to
execute a physical repair I don't
remember if it was an E or a BAC related
repair that was going to be done and
every patient experienced the sort of
pre surgical process of getting ready
for surgery
every patient had an incision done while
under general anesthesia but some
patients after the incision were
immediately sewn back up and no repair
was actually made whereas other patients
had the actual surgery and it was
determined that the patients who were
prepped for surgery had an incision done
were anesthetized but no repair was
executed showed a significant
improvement comparable to that of those
patients who actually had the physical
repair done how can we understand that
placebo response
is it the expectation that they would
feel better after a surgery was done
well it's very important to emphasize
that in those studies to study the
studies you are mentioned mentioning
about surgery for example as a surgery
is very difficult to see what is going
on in the patient's after fake surgery
or real surgery because those studies
with fake surgery with placebo surgery
you can't really rule out the
possibility of spontaneous remission
there are no appropriate control groups
for example there are no what we call no
treatment group of natural history group
or waiting list group you know in which
there is no treatment no surgery for
example so in those studies in those
surgery studies there is no appropriate
control group so actually actually I am
pretty skeptical because because there
could be and you can really rule out the
possibility of spontaneous remission so
and just to make sure that that's clear
to the audience there are lots of
conditions that resolve on their own is
what you're sort of getting at and when
I'm compare a treatment to a placebo you
also sort of really need a group that
has no treatment at all because you do
need to account for the fact that there
are many conditions and symptoms that
would go away without any treatment
whatsoever that's correct we are
perfectly the right absolutely the main
problem is that if you want if you want
to understand the placebo response you
need to compare two groups the first
group is a group with no treatment just
no treatment group is used for assessing
spontaneous remission that spontaneous
time course of symptom or disease you
know over time and the second group the
second group receives a plus
so the difference between the no
treatment group and the placebo group is
this the real placebo response which
means the real psychological effect if
you don't have a spontaneous remission
group a natural history group or if you
prefer to call it a no treatment group
it is not really possible to rule out
spontaneous remission natural history of
the of the disease so in surgery
unfortunately we don't have no treatment
groups so it is a possible after surgery
after fake surgery after I mean placebo
surgery it is possible that there was a
small town or emissions it was not a
real psychological effect it was not a
real a placebo effect so I mean that the
the topic is quite complex you know but
the main point is that there is a real
psychological effect and it is the real
plastic effect there is a fake placebo
effect it is not a real psychological
effect it is a spontaneous remission how
if at all does the reality of the
placebo response impact sort of the
business of the pharmaceutical industry
and I guess what I mean by that is if we
concede that there are many cases in
which a patient would benefit this to
the same degree or almost the same
degree from a placebo treatment as they
would from a presumably more expensive
real treatment for lack of a better term
is that not a threat to the
pharmaceutical industry to some degree
yes well I can say by the way that drug
companies are very very much interested
in placebo research for two reasons yeah
the reason the first reason is that they
would like to develop new designs for
clinical trials of course because some
designs today are not really
satisfactory for answer is to answer in
many many questions
you know the second reason is that drug
companies would like to predict in
advance who is good placebos
ponder was not so drug companies are
very very much interested in in in
placebo research and sometimes as you
said the reserved no difference between
the response to a real drag to a real
treatment and to triplet sebum that
would be a very very interesting for for
drug companies from a practical point of
view as well because just consider a
condition in which there is no
difference between a placebo and the
drug so is it possible to really use in
clinical practice I mean not in the
clinical trial setting but in clinical
practice is it really possible to use a
placebo in place of a real drag many say
yes many many people say no for ethical
limitations of whose political reasons
I've thought about that quite a bit
because if we take for a second sort of
the group of conditions that sometimes
are psychosomatic conditions or
conditions related to an emotional
situation in someone's life so insomnia
for example or headaches of no
determined origin you can imagine you
know sort of what other conditions would
be on that list it's very clear that
many of the individuals suffering from
that would improve merely by being told
here's a pill that will help you and it
seems to me that there's a real
opportunity there to have people improve
with a with a placebo pill a pill that
would have no side effects by virtue of
not really having active ingredients but
what are the ethics of that in other
words it would only work if the patient
doesn't know that it's a fake pill and
that would raise ethical questions about
the prescriber would it not yeah
absolutely you are right it is possible
to use a placebo pill to use a fake bill
in routine medical practice you can give
you can give not so much a fake PR which
means you can give instead of sugar
pilla or
instead of giving a glass of fresh water
you can a very very small dose of a real
drag for example just imagine a
situation in which you give morphine an
effective dose of morphine is more or
less 10 milligrams you know that's the
effective dose of morphine but you can
just - just to overcome the ethical
problem you can give a very very small
dose not ten milligrams but just one
milligram for example and one milligram
is actually a placebo because there is
not there is not a dose pharmacological
dose which can be really effective that
to reduce pain so if you reduce the dose
from 10 milligrams to 1 milligram and
you increase the patient's expectations
actually you can overcome the ethical
problem which means that actually you
don't give a sugar pill but you give a
very very very small dose of a drug last
thing I want to touch on what other
areas in society might be might benefit
from explorations of the placebo
response outside of the sort of medical
settings you and I have mostly been
discussing in I would say in everyday
life just to give you an example I live
in an area here in northern Italy where
there is a very good wine and if you
come to Italy to my area and you taste
wine and they tell you it is Italian
wine probably taste is much better it's
really very very good wine even though
it is not really tallien wine but I
don't know wine from any other country
for example so your expectation I mean
works in everyday life not only in the
clinical setting but for in for food for
you know drink sell for wine and for
dresses as well for example the style is
that you know work very much on this
aspect
expectations about about style
another example well I live in Italy of
course so for fashion fashion Italian
fashion is quite important famous all
over the world and if I tell you this is
an Italian dress a probably you expect a
very very good dress so in conclusion I
mean we we found we find that a placebo
or if you prefer properly it is not
correct to call it a placebo we can call
expectation expectation are very very
importantly everyday life yeah the wine
placebo studies wine expectation studies
that have been done are actually very
very interesting we've been speaking
with professor of physiology and
neuroscience Fabrizio benedetti who's
joining us from northern Italy today
thanks you thank you so much for talking
to me about this thank you very much